ladies and gentlemen  here's the deal with ladies and  gentlemen  here's the deal  gays and gentlemen here's the deal that  was the president last Tuesday his  messaging has not gotten better  yesterday in Yonkers New York Biden  nearly fell over while campaigning for  the unelected governor Kathy hokel  we put a cap of two thousand dollars a  year on prescription drugs for seniors  no matter what their cost  2 10 12.50 oops stepping on them there's  a it's black anyway  make it end subscribe to the Fox News  YouTube channel to catch our nightly  opens stories that are changing the  world and changing your life from Tucker  Carlson tonight